hey I'm Gary and you're watching the
askgaryvee show
Tippett summary question every question
this is a great question on this episode
I talk about fantasy baseball Instagram
makeup artists and what do people really
want out of social media you ask
questions and I answer them
this is the ask Gary Vee shut up
jab
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 77 of the ask gary vee
show sup everyone this has been a clunky
2015 I've been traveling my ass off so I
don't feel like we're in a rhythm and
it's not going to continue March is the
disaster for the askgaryvee show I'm
just setting the tone right now for
everybody I apologize but I want to give
a huge shout out to all the fans that
are watching watching watching and
listening watching live on meerkat
that's an actual animal for all of you
that don't know you know I appreciate
all of you I know that when shows are
not consistent one of the great things I
learned in 2006 7/8 was Wine Library was
winning cuz it was Monday Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday Friday and it was
every day five days a week for years
because I was always at the store never
vacationing and that helped it this show
doesn't have that luxury though we have
modern technology getting pinged when
things are on and things of that nature
and so I really appreciate all of you
into that I appreciate the people that
are subscribed to the podcast are
subscribed to my YouTube page are part
of my email service do follow me on
social I think none of these things for
granted and I want to start episode 77
with an enormous just outrageous
completely authentic and furious thank
you hey Gary Vee this is Carl this is
Mike and on a recent podcast Carla might
we answered five your questions of the
day five minutes that's it Carl and Mike
asked Gary what do most people want to
get out of social media
Carl Mike first and foremost I just
instructed India let's show India you
know because India just told me an
awesome story that like people are
starting to recognize her from the show
your India from the askgaryvee show I
love that call Mike listen it's very
simple well people want out of social
media completely maps to what they want
out of life there is you know social
media internet life internet culture I
was saying something the other day that
mean culture has taken over culture
talking on the vaynermedia team you know
because the Internet is life and so what
people want on a social media are the
things they wanted
life they want the fame and notoriety
India they want you know they want they
want they want this you know what they
want out of social media they want this
my friend right because they want this
in real life they want they want a place
to express their art and show the world
their art India you know and so like
these are the things that people want
exactly what you want in like what do I
want at a social media I wanted to
interact with more people
I wanted the vanity of being like are
you Gary Vee sure I'm you want to think
of selfie like I want it to fit fill the
things that were in my heart getting out
there leaving a legacy not realizing how
much I love to teach but that's what
Wine Library TV and the askgaryvee show
are who knew a student a teacher and so
like the things are really interesting
to me are that people want what they
actually want and what social media
allows them to do my friend is use the
backbone of the Internet to cut out the
middle of the gatekeepers that used to
keep us away from that who the [ __ ]
would have hired me as a college
professor teaching marketing no one
guess what that is what's interesting
about the world we're living in now
direct-to-consumer my friends you want
to watch me on the show you want to
follow me how many people on meerkat
right now in the middle of the day
there's 318 people that are busy in the
middle of day get back to work
that are deciding that this is valuable
to their time bunch of about people are
about to reply this is work and you're
right this is good content I appreciate
it and so that's what it allows to do it
allows us to actually map exactly what
you actually want in life because you
have no restrictions to actually achieve
it
sandy asks Gary how do you maintain a
good pleasant mood with family after a
long day of hustle sanely great question
India was it you applied an email it was
like yeah I want to know that answer too
look here's the thing I you know this is
only one person I've always had and my
dad did not do this well and maybe
that's why it affected me I am so
grateful and so thankful to the family
members that allow me my wife
specifically allow me the freedom to
hustle the way I do I feel like it's
totally inappropriate to disrespect
that love to then carry over my
headaches home in general and this is
something that the people that know me
best
then the nicest thing they can say to me
and it happened you know been said to me
12 times in my life nothing but my best
friend Brandon who runs Wine Library my
mom my sister my wife AJ my dad hasn't
anyway there's been a couple people that
have have said to me how much they
admire that I never take my headaches
out on them I think there's really at
the end of day two people people that
need somebody else to dump their
headaches on and people that collect
those headaches
I admire my mom tremendously she
collects everybody's headaches I'm very
thankful that I took that DNA I'm
thrilled to hear your headaches but I
have no interest in giving you mine and
so that foundation that DNA trade allows
me to walk right in home with all the
insanity lost this client cashflows not
as good problem can't ship this state
anymore didn't get that deal this deal
fell through didn't get that opportunity
number two in the New York Times you
know something way worse than that like
somebody's leaving that I don't want
somebody's sick that I don't want that
be sick all these things that are life
and they're intense the second I walk in
that door I need to repay that amazing
family that has given me the opportunity
to do my thing I need to shut that all
off and turn on a different gear and the
truth is it's just easy for me no
different than when Kobe Stefan loves
Kobe show stuff on you know when Kobe
goes on the court he becomes a different
character that's how I'm very much like
that on stage different dude right now
different dude running this company
different dude walk in the house
different dude and so I just have a lot
of gears I'd gear it up nine present
from nine present makeup on Instagram
and I am a 10 year old make partisan I
just have one simple question I post
books on Instagram and people ask me to
like their pictures in exchange they
like my pictures and I was just
wondering how you would handle that nyah
first of all adore the Hustle crushed
that I wasn't lucky like you and wasn't
born during the Internet era do you know
how much fun these two would have mixing
up videos of me talking trash as a 12
year old baseball card dealer we can
had an amazing narrative I'm pissed and
watching you talk about your your
background in this short little video
including the fact that you said I'm a
makeup artist on Instagram right that
has been for a lot of people that that's
a little moment in there that I want
everybody to wrap their head around not
on YouTube on Instagram the mediums
continue to change the experts in those
mediums that move first and best will
always win I love what I wrote and crush
it oh I don't know six years ago coming
through Naya is soon crush it's gonna be
older than the people asking questions
on the show Naya is a real-life version
of that dream come true for me so I
appreciate you for that Naya oh I like
what you're doing there Stefan's the fun
by the way is trying to take a picture
of the screen taking them is so goddamn
meta over here if it's insane podcasters
I know a lot of you love listening but
this is the episode to watch just to see
what meta stephane is up to now the
answer is I'm not a big fan of that it
doesn't feel authentic you like my post
I like your post there's something about
the Karma and the energy of that kind of
tactic that I think doesn't really work
and so what I would recommend you to do
is be a good Samaritan and a good
community of Instagram fashion world
user meaning I would spend an hour of
the day going through all the people who
are actually putting out content that
you actually do like and heart that up
and take the 10 to 20 percent of people
that then find you because of that and
then the 10 percent of that 10 percent 1
percent that authentically want to give
you love back and there's something
bound in that authenticity that is so
much greater than the scale of the
growth hacking or the blackhat growth
hacking that that is that I don't think
brings you as much value as you may
think so darling if you're willing to
listen to me I think you go about it the
highbrow way but the way to get results
and the way I got results on Twitter was
you actually got to go out and give some
love you have to take a power of your
time and give some love and so the first
thing I would do is watch this video
then go directly to your parents and
find out if you can go to sleep an hour
later each night so that you can
actually execute this amber asks Gary
how do you motivate teams of remote
workers without a payment incentive
so far positivity and hustle are not
producing results I think communication
is key but I'm not sure how to improve
it amber you're exactly right and
there's several things here that are a
problem and we need to address
amber number one communication is always
key you don't know how to address it
because you don't want to address it my
darling because it's very easy to
address communication you create the
scenario for communication what I would
do is I would email more texts or hit up
on gchat or however stack or whatever
the way you guys roll hit them up and
say I want to talk to you d rock I want
to talk to you Stefan I want to talk to
you India I want to talk to you Davis
like that is basically what you do in
that scenario you create the
communication and then you ask them hey
India hey India you're not executing to
the level that I'm hoping but I'm gonna
blame that on me what can I do for you
to make you execute better that works
and so that's what you need to do
one-on-one scalable if you have one
employee to place you don't scares me
and you can leave this in the comments
what scares me is how many employees are
we talking about because I'm trying to
do it for 500 and I'm funny feeling
you're not talking about 500 so this is
on you hey Gary
Mathieu Burri here from ESPN and you and
I are friends in real life so I happen
to know in addition to all the other
things that you're into you happen to
love fantasy sports especially your
fantasy baseball and you know that in
addition to my duties at ESPN happened
to also own two websites
roto pass calm and roto Pass baseball
calm both these sites cater to fantasy
sports enthusiasts and frankly I want to
know what I can do to take it to the
next level I'm lucky in that I have a
nice platform here at ESPN and on my
Twitter and Facebook social media
platforms to be able to throat the site
but ultimately it's just me and I want
to expand the site beyond just my reach
what can I do to make the site go viral
what can I do to increase sales to
increase visibility of the site I don't
want to take on money or try to raise
anything like that again it's just me so
what can I do to
take those sites to the next level
Matthew first of all big shadow I love
your work
we are friends in real life and digital
life two minutes first of all I hate
fantasy football and have never played
it and never will because my lover -
Jeff is too intense and I don't want to
hear all the explanations from everybody
in the comment section
leave it for yourself none of them are
valid I do love fantasy baseball I'm
getting ready for our draft I'm super
pumped look I think it's content content
content my friend so first of all the
first thing you should do is so many so
many people want to be in the fantasy
baseball fantasy football fantasy sports
industry so the first thing is the
exposure of this shows question alone
puts you in the game I bet you that if
Matthew you go into my YouTube channel
right now you will see 11 people that
will volunteer to be an intern to work
on this project because they want to put
themselves on the map and you've got
brand equity like I kind of you know was
weird my first inkling to answer this is
like let me write a guest weekly column
about like my sleeper picks each week
because I want exposure in that world
and you're the platform for it and I'm
busy and I'm rich and I really still
would do it because I don't need to get
paid I want the exposure right and by
the way I said I was rich and I want
everybody understand that
because if you're poor or not as many
dollars it should make you want to do it
even more that's the brain twist that
everybody doesn't see anyway you need to
put it out in the world Matthew that I
need five - you need to take a day of
your time and that 50 to 100 people and
see if they can bring you value create a
team that you give exposure to and then
you need to put out content basically
you need to reread Jab Jab Jab right
hook and you put need to put out fantasy
sports content native look what's
happened to this world with my content
on medium and Linkedin like I mean you
need to put up where's your weekly video
that you put on a Facebook of your
sleeper pick that then gets amplified
you need to put out content the answer
to your question is content content
content especially in fantasy content is
a gateway drug to subscription you need
to figure out how to afford or use your
leverage to bring value to youngsters
youngsters normally but maybe oldsters
you'll be retired
and dudes would do this as well because
it's fun you need to find the right
person that matches up to this
opportunity that wants your brand equity
in exchange for their work because they
love doing the work because they want to
talk about how much of a sleeper James
Paxton is gonna be this year in baseball
question of the day I am preparing for
my fantasy baseball league so I need
your fantasy baseball sleeper if you
have no idea what the hell I'm talking
about
give me your technology app sleeper
don't use meerkat have a wonderful day I
love you I love the show oh and I'm
gonna throw hook a little bit here I
need podcasts reviews and subscriptions
d-roc do it up you keep asking questions
I'll keep answering them
of course she's like mom bedtime was 9
now can I be content Gary you tie me in
because I'm going let's go let's move
Matt give me a look what
[Music]
[Music]
yeah yeah
[Music]